Foreign Affairs select committee spoke
to her yesterday Alicia Kearns hi you
must be relieved somewhat I think
enormous relief but I think all of us
need to hold mod foreign office all the
armed forces and everyone on the ground
Sudan in our hearts because as we all
know the ceasefire didn't hold on
Saturday for more than three hours and
this is our window to get people out so
I think we all have to hope as hard as
we can okay it is supposed to be 72
hours there are 4 000 Brits either
holding a passport or dual nationality
so obviously holding a passport for
other reasons married to Brits or
whatever
um
4072 hours do the math the numbers don't
necessarily add up but at the same time
we know that not everyone who has
registered with the foreign office of
those numbers actually wants to be
evacuated
um so look they've said they're going to
get passport holders out they're going
to prioritize women children the
vulnerable those medical needs that is
absolutely the right thing to do but it
is a Race Against Time and we just have
to hope that during this period of the
ceasefire the Diplomatic work doesn't
stop so the goal now has to be what
happens next how do we make sure that
this doesn't transition back to conflict
but transition to some sort of formal
peace talks or negotiation beyond that
and what role can the Brits play in that
absolutely key we are the UN Security
Council what's called a pen holder which
means essentially we lead on Sudan the
UN Security Council clearly the
Americans have taken a big run the
ceasefire I'm really proud of the fact
that James cleverley was right that we
could get a ceasefire I have my doubts
so now the UK needs to continue the role
it's playing currently in convening and
talking to Partners around the world and
we need to make sure we don't see a
return to violence so what role do you
can we say the Brits have played in the
ceasefire I think we'll be finding that
out probably hopefully today at some
point when we'll hear a statement
hopefully from the foreign secretary but
it is quite clear that the Diplomatic
work has been constant he's been
speaking to all our allies the African
Union Emirates the Americans the
Americans announced the ceasefire though
so it does look like they were first and
foremost you know organizing it okay 72
hours is generally just a window to
allow those who want to leave to be able
to leave it's not as straightforward as
that though no this is still incredibly
complex we have two warring factions
these are not well organized well
managed well-trained Armed Forces you
could have Renegade factions within it
you will have individuals who will be
high on the joy of looting who could
commit further crimes and that is why
British Nationals need to stay where
they are and only come forward when they
are contacted by the foreign office
because a plane is waiting for them and
they're ready to be able to move them
safely to the evacuation point is your
understanding that it will be an airlift
rather than see at this point they are
going to continue to use the airlift
just north of Khartoum however we know
that that airstrip has been degrading
it's not of high quality and the foreign
office did suggest that they may look at
other routes depending on how things go
forward and we know there are
friendships and UK ships within the
region so they may just be waiting to
bring those forward should the airlift
either not be able to get enough people
out at speed or if there are problems
that arise with that and those will be
just military aircraft I mean um given
what happened in Afghanistan we won't
bring in like 380s from British Airways
or whatever I suspect it will be
Hercules and other aircraft that are
expert at Landing even the most
difficult of circumstances but we will
have to wait and see how do we make sure
it's not um Afghanistan 2.0 I mean it's
such a different situation to
Afghanistan this is very limited there
are so many more threats so many more
complexities to this the reality now is
making sure the foreign office can
contact everyone because the big worry
is yes people registered with the
foreign office but telecoms have gone
down since then electricity has gone
down to people's phones that might not
be charged so now the foreign office
will be doing the most impossible task
which is contacting every single person
and those they can't contact we've got
to work out how to reach out to them
shouldn't we have been doing this before
now
I would have liked to have seen an
evacuation at earlier point but James
cleverley took the position that it was
not safe to evacuate before there was a
season started they did but at the same
time French and Turkish not Nationals
were shot at there was a French Marine
that is now in a critical condition
James cleverley's view was he did not
want to see a British child shot at
while being evacuated and that suggests
that that's because he was so close to
the ceasefire negotiations that he had
High Hopes it would be agreed but yes I
was Gravely concerned I wasn't confident
as ceasefire could be achieved they've
proved me wrong on that so now we have
to hope that it holds and they can get
people out but yes we have been pushing
very hard for evacuation clearly they
have been considering it but thankfully
they got the ceasefire and now we can
evacuate people and safety and you are
confident that 4 000 people can come out
in 72 hours I'm not comfortable with one
thousand want to
um but let me raise the question those
who want to come out will be able to get
out in 72 hours I have to hope and in
diplomacy if you don't have hope you
have nothing but is that an enormous
feat is the enormous task yes but the
government has also suggested that
they'll be leaning quite heavily on
other partners from around the world so
it may be that others are going to help
us get some of ours out okay busy day
ahead for you please keep us informed
thank you very much indeed thank you
um